hi guys I'm Sam from pixie boot welcome
to the lipstick diaries today we are
going to be talking about berry colored
lipsticks these gorgeous colors I'm
actually going to do a quick makeup
tutorial and show you how to wear them
so we're going to start with a bit of
foundation foundation I've chosen
it's a Rimmel BB cream why am I using a
BB cream because the lipstick is going
to be quite strong so I want to keep
everything else quite light and sheer
I'm going to use a buffing brush just to
work that into the skin color I'm using
is medium it's going to give us like a
really pretty light coverage not like in
color light as in sheer this has got an
SPF of 20 in it so that's good it's also
got loads of moisturizing properties so
it's going to keep you looking nice and
youthful all day so what we got that
worked in we can put a little bit for
your browser you probably notice that I
don't have a lot of brown there so what
I'm going to do is just fill them in
with a little bit of a brown mascara so
I want to keep this super simple so it's
something that you can recreate at home
so I'm doing this super fast and easy so
this is just like a normal mascara but
you can't really use a normal mascara on
your brows because it kind of sets and
then it will go flaky this has a little
bit of movement in it so you won't get
that kind of flakiness various shades
are pretty bold so we need to do a
little bit of balancing on the eyes we
don't want to go too much on we might
look over made-up I'm going to use this
this is glam eyes HD and this is [ __ ]
grey so it's all sort of grays and
blacks in here I'm going to start off by
using this grey here now depending on
how much space you've got between your
eyelashes and your eyebrows will depend
on how high you'll take the eyeshadow
obviously you can see there's a lot of
room here from here to here so I'm going
to blend that shallow pretty high up
towards the brow but if you have a lower
brow just keep that eye shadow closer to
the
okay add definition let's go in with a
black looks scary not so scary and we're
just going to run this along the lash
line now don't try and make it too neat
we don't want to make it to me because
sometimes especially we're going to go a
pretty neat on the lips it's quite nice
for it not to be totally perfect in
other places now you can never not go
perfect on the skin so the eyes is the
obvious place to do that so leave it a
little bit messy and little bit undone
along the lash line if you feel like you
want to take whatever is left on your
brush just underneath the lash line
you're kind of definitely go with this
the more 80s it will look so keep it
nice and smudgy and then mascara you
want a nice extreme black mascara give
your lashes a bit of a wiggle and a
flick just pop a bit of concealer on
just under the eyes before we move on to
the lips concealer is really really
important because these pinky lipsticks
can amplify any pink in your face so we
need to make sure that we're taking any
of the darkness around the eyes out and
anything around the nose and any
blemishes that we might have just so the
lips are the main focus okay so very
lips they're so hot right now first of
all you want to decide what kind of
texture you want now I have three
different textures from Rimmel the
moisture in you this is a great lipstick
if you find that your lips get dry
during the day when wearing lipstick
this is super moisturizing formula very
very comfortable to wear for bakka lips
this is a 16 hour lipstick so it's going
to be very very long-lasting then we've
got lasting finished color rush this is
a long lasting intense color lip balm so
again super moisturizing but very very
strong in color all of these are very
strong in color
actually which is exactly what we want
because that's the Nick now I don't know
what to choose I'm kind of drawn towards
the pravakar lips okay I have committed
to provoking it sixteen-hour the color
is not guilty I like the name first of
all we're going to pop the color on
look at that color fantastic
so when you put step one on which is the
intense color it goes on super glossy
glides on so it's really really easy to
wear but you will feel it start to set
so I can feel it's getting a little bit
tacky now now once you get to that tacky
stage you move on to step two which is
the lock and shine you pop this over the
top
you can tell it's gonna last all day
because there's nothing coming up on the
little lip balm applicator at all none
of that color at all so there's a really
quick and easy makeup to go with your
very lips this season now if you're
going out on the town then I would
suggest the pravakar lips that's going
to stay on all night regardless of how
much you drink if you find your lips get
dry then try the moisture renew they're
brilliant I'll just show you these three
colors because they're beautiful these
are absolutely beautiful color so here
we've got amethyst shimmer which is a
shimmery kind of purple pink then we've
got diva red which is like your true
true red and then here we've got as you
want Victoria which is a really nice
kind of bright vibrant pink love those
they are gorgeous
and very comfortable to wear all day and
then I sort of think about these kind of
these bright lip balms as being more of
your weekend coverage I'm going to show
you these colors too so you can see the
three colors on the bottom here beaver
violet rumor has it and all you need is
pink that's everything for today guys
thank you so much for watching I hope
you've enjoyed it give it a gun and I
will catch up with you next time take
care bye